what's your process for creating each
episode of trailer image and tell us
more about really oh well trailer hitch
is like the you know trailer hitch is
just something that I just super enjoy
doing mostly because Allen Havey who
plays kind of crotchety uncle al at
somebody great actor great comedian you
know who's been in on everything from
you know Curb Your Enthusiasm to Louie
and he had his own show night after
night with Allen Havey which was sort of
like the evolution of the David
Letterman Show really interesting and
he'd done him he's a he's at the improv
desi great great funny comedian and
actor I've known him forever and he's a
hardcore movie geek but he's also a
generation older than myself and we've
always had this sort of like I don't
know if it's a sort of a collision of
generations but we've always had this
banter whenever we go see a movie
together which we do we watch movie
together there's this thing that happens
and I don't pretend to be a comic like
Alan I mean Alan is a professional
comedian and I prefer to be sort of the
straight man to his to his comic you
know ability so really it just becomes
about him kind of letting it rip with
these kind of philosophies or attitudes
about a John or whether it's a zombie
movie or a vampire movie or what he
thinks looks I like giving this next in
this episode of world wars we did on
world war z which is the brad pitt sort
of epic zombie movie coming out based on
the book which is a whole world you know
swarming with zombies and we watched
that trailer you know allen's uncle al's
response to zombies zombies don't run
you know zombies are slow and
disoriented and remember in the old days
when zombies were just sort of stumbling
and I'm trying to explain to him as a
slightly younger viewer that since like
28 days later zombies run and that it's
not just walking stumbling and so this
whole sort of natural banter kind of
comes out as we watch these these
trailers and it's very loose it's very
very improvised what he does is we
decide on a trailer that we want to
review or not even review really just
kind of just observe and common
and then Allen goes home and essentially
sort of bullet points almost like punch
lines that he knows what he's going to
get into and then I just sort of set it
up and this like really react to what he
says was what he said what he tends to
say is usually fairly outlandish so all
I have to do is go huh wow you know I'm
basically like by Abbott to his Luke I
so he can just go crazy and I'll just go
give a look and that's really that's
really how we do it so we just kind of
literally we come into this room here
and we set up like just two mics and we
plug it and we put earphones we share
your phones we look at the trailer on a
laptop and then we just let it run and
then we just we run it like three or
four times and we just do it and then I
just end up editing the best bits
together and then we send it to an
animator Oliver dear who was actually my
art director on some guy who kills
people he did all the illustrations all
the comic book illustrations and some
guy and he animates it for so he
animates it to the audio track and then
we sort of just come back here and put
it all together but it's a it's fun it's
like it's not so much scripted as just
sort of a recorded conversation or
sometimes a rant you know sometimes so
him he had a funny take on people that
watch the hobbit like 30 root and they
smell funny we couldn't get a job at the
Renaissance Faire something like that
right so anyway yeah yeah what's so
funny the hobbit you know the thing is
is that the hobbit it's so interesting
we talked about YouTube we did this
episode on the hobbit and I'm a Lord of
the Rings fan you know and I I'm a big
fan and and it's interesting because
uncle al's take on the hobbit is exactly
what you're talking about what is this
you know what are these dwarves and
elves and what is they and it's like
it's like an old like like like very
much like an Archie Bunker like it just
a sort of like a semi ignorant character
who has no problem like you know
pontificating and spouting whatever even
if he doesn't really know about it or
even if he does know about it but so
many hobbed fans are Lord of the Rings
fans or like took offense but like I
hate uncle Alan he doesn't know how dare
you say anything it's like you know it's
a cartoon you know it's not it's not
like it's not like somebody coming out
and
and it's a comedy piece so it's
interesting to see how passionate you
know for me like if you love something
it's okay to make fun of it I mean it's
actually better to make fun of something
that you love but it's interesting to
see how protective people are of it so
um I'm keep seeing different comments
some people are like take it easy this
is really funny you know this has not
meant to offend Lord of the Rings fans
and I'm constantly saying hey look i'm a
fan i know you know Uncle Al is just a
character you know you know so it's
interesting orange so you apply to these
yeah I do you know it's funny how
ordinarily I wouldn't and and but part
of the part of the whole YouTube
experience and again i'm a newbie in
this world is sort of the communication
or engagement i think that's one of the
things that's different about television
are certainly different from television
is that there is a communication that
goes on between the people who make the
shows and the people who watch the shows
in that on any given youtube videos
obviously million comments if something
is interesting or inflammatory whatever
people comment and youtube actually
encourages the people who make the
videos at least for the premium channels
to engage because that that that's part
of the experience is saying you know hey
you know this is what we met or you know
like or thanks for some lump sum people
just leave very nice comments you're
like thanks you know for watching and
you know next week we're going to do
this movie and so i think that's part of
that world but i'm so used to movies
we're basically you know making a movie
you put it out there and maybe read a
couple of reviews and as long as
somebody doesn't send you you know dog
in the mail or so or a hate letter
or something then that's basically it
that's the end of the communication you
know so so yeah
you